an ominous start
israeli police making arrests in the old
city
they scuffle close to damascus gate a
sign of heightened tension
ahead of planned protests the
demonstrators came to chant against
israel's airstrikes on gaza
and to vent a wider sense of injustice
it's not tolerated for long
we've just moved from damascus gate to
hear this flashpoint neighborhood
of sheikh shirara and across the road
you can see the protesters have started
their chants again while watching them
on the other side of the road
are the israeli police and there's
definitely a sense of tension in the air
the police again on the offensive
they move in with stun grenades rubber
bullets and a water cannon
that sprays stinking liquid uh
these protests were part of a day of
demonstrations and strikes
in arab neighborhoods inside israel and
across the west bank
this was the scene in bethlehem
tear gas fired to push back the crowds
evidence the conflict between israel and
hamas in gaza
has sparked far wider unrest
little sign of any imminent pause
with new israeli airstrikes on the
enclave despite
efforts to stop the fighting and
mounting concern about civilian deaths
though there was a slight change as two
trucks of much-needed aid were allowed
in
but this is why israel says it needs to
keep striking
a hamas rocket fired from gaza killed
two thai workers
on an israeli farm close to the border
for the deputy mayor in jerusalem
israel's military action is justified
they've armed themselves to the teeth
with a blockade imagine what they would
have done without one we can't trust
you know israel can't lose one war it
would be genocide here if we lost one
war
but palestinians say they can't tolerate
the status quo
it'll take much more than a ceasefire to
calm these streets
debra haynes skynews jerusalem